what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
a compilation mark a player not getting
over it rage compilation one of our top
reward tiers on our patient pages ever
video your request we must doing put up
on youtubes and today comes from
birthday boy McHale Linden I'm excited
to check this out because I've seen a
few of markiplier x' videos never
actually any of his gaming videos though
I've seen like where he's vlogging or
having a very serious discussion to the
camera the truth is the most important
thing that we could ever learn about
ourselves honesty is the only glue that
keeps together communities on the
internet or doing a wired autocomplete
interview what what is markiplier like
in real life kind of a toll
I mean I'm nice so I've seen a lot of
markiplier except for the main thing
he's known for and also for years people
have always been like well it's Greg
look at markiplier was itamarca bar this
guy looks like markiplier now after
looking at markiplier and then looking
at me I realized imagine if Superman
Clark Kent had a twin brother and he
didn't come out anywhere near as
good-looking as him but you could tell
they're brothers it's like you know Vin
Diesel has that twin and you're like oh
Vin Diesel definitely got the better
side of that arrangement no well now you
know no idea that's kind of the
markiplier situation I'm in looks like I
have a deep voice he has a deeper voice
we have similar facial features and
looks he just has it a much more
superhero aesthetic I'm glad to be
number two to this guy in terms of looks
subscriber count' Wow he's almost caught
up to us
yep I have actually seen a number of
multipliers five nights at Freddy's
videos oh sorry I've seen the thing he's
done and it's quite entertaining I'm
excited for this
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to this Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun Fun
Fun Fun Fun Fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a very hard game yeah
very geometry alright
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh doggy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is a soundproof I can see why yeah
it was like fun upset yeah
yeah we apply these it was just calm you
probably would have saw this I feel like
this game
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he does look like an intensely
challenging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this game would be really simple
probably so keek you do only two things
this is probably more fun with a camera
pointed hey you probably and when it's
like one prolonged session and rather
than a compilation the same kind of
[Music]
Oh fry tears to my eyes the pumpkin down
Oh No hey sir play this there's only so
much you can do
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's go through chairs a must and
drywall
why did I have to change things the
hubris neighbors ever here
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah see why is so famous yeah receipt of
him like rarest I watch this video
called the truth he talks so serious
gravitas video who's talking directly to
the camera or anytime I see enemies very
like calm and reserved or feeling very
emotional like oh this is what's made
famous and I see why he's got a lot of
emotion to express but he plays these
games this is all I know markiplier and
you have a totally different image - oh
yeah I associate American Flyers like oh
he's like really like philosophical
there's no one that's gonna stop us from
doing some good and it's gonna be great
yeah freaks out and very music was most
people gnome is that I never heard that
before but I've never actually seen it
yeah yeah yeah I this this did look
supremely frustrating it does it doesn't
look like it would be that hard of
course not that's why why it's
frustrating though I feel like I should
be able to get this game down and
because I'm not getting it down it's
very frustrating I feel like this is a
game that goads you into a trap where
it's like you see a video like this
you're like I can do all right I can
figure out the physics of this and then
you download steam and you fall down the
hole yourself yeah what's funny is is
that even though he's having such a
difficult time with it in hating the
game and even like did a little bit of
an opacity effect there with with the
tweets of how much he hates the game it
probably helped get this game a lot more
downloads o purchases you know honestly
even on our end while watches I'm like
on trust game I don't think I can do it
yeah because I'm right now I'm there
doing exactly we're talking about going
yeah I think I can do this I can pull
this off yeah yeah cuz also you see the
same level so many times in this
compilation that you're like well I
would just go there yeah yeah like what
could if you keep doing the same thing
you've done you just gonna get the same
result yeah yeah see this is fascinating
to me because this compilation I'm sure
has been distilled down out of a water
time and yeah it felt like character arc
where it's like at first it's like okay
like we know we're getting into this is
a rage game apparently like it's
probably why he played it in the first
place so at first it's fun and then in
the middle it starts to become like an
actual frustration then 3/4 of the way
through it seems like he's actually
really upset playing like there's a
certain point where the compilation
itself just becomes he touches the game
for a second and then immediately gets
up at least yeah I really seemed like
you pushed him too well it seems like a
very frustrating experience yeah but
dude like literally I've known him as
like a really deep rather reserved guy
and then seeing this side of him hit my
ha the shades of market videos oh yeah
no I love the other side of him like
Lucy names because you know you could
hear hero one day when he's like in a
very emotional state you know his voice
is a little bit higher you shut the [ __ ]
off but whenever he's caught me could
hear that real like soothing deep voice
that he has one of the coolest thing
that's ever come out of this channel is
the ability to be honest with each other
Sarah toned yeah it's a really has a
very very lovely boys you should narrate
audiobooks [ __ ] or am i voicemail for me
you know he should dirty talk to my
girlfriend when I'm making love to her
just send the script of what you guys
want to have so my phone recordings up
to her here yeah so long yeah that's
great and then I'll do the rage
compilation voices - in the middle of
why but it's a humor though - it's like
you could tell the times where he's
genuinely just pissed and the time is
we're playing you know he's playing yeah
obviously no he's playing it up and like
feeding off of the frustration to
enhance the humor when he's doing that
stuff there's some like
hidden genie I don't know people call
him a comedian but there is some hidden
genius comedy there yeah in the sense of
like that part Romani tears because it
seems so natural to I go there so
frustrated that you're letting it out
well yeah those because I'm not that
same kind of thing but yeah I think it's
one of those moments where you catch
yourself about to like scream and you're
like I gotta do something else with yeah
I gotta let out this energy some other
way even when the way he just repeats
the same word over fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
I'm having [ __ ] if I know it's funny cuz
of how he just keeps repeating yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that blunt-force comedy
of like it starts funny and then it kind
of loses it and then it comes back
around just for how insistent he is
there's been quite a few channels who I
started watching on my own time over the
years from what people have recommended
for us to check out here at the real
rejects and like I said I've gone down
the markiplier deep speaking route which
are a lot you know further a viewer than
these kind of videos but now I feel like
I'm gonna start binging it was like five
nights at freddys that's the woman I
love it was most popular and once right
yeah it's fun to watch them get scared
I imagine so he looks like a guy who's
very reactive yeah get ready for that
high register
all right well mchao Linda thanks so
much for requesting this dude right now
I know you're taking a little break from
patreon I mean his pledge is still there
and that's what matters most of all of
our friends especially the seven other
people who owe me money for those
in-game tickets anyway don't worry Jon
it crossed you off the list I got your
venmo
thanks man the Martin Kaymer Clark
became listen mark McHale I hope you're
having a fun time I think he said he's
in Poland who for his birthday
whoo that's exciting get eleven people
gotta pull in for the birthday from
Sweden maybe you're having a good time
you just turned the big six five who 65
years old he'll tell you he's turning 40
don't believe him I've seen this guy's
photos the guy clearly is no younger
than 63 at most so even though he's like
celebrate the big 400 I'm like typing
yeah all right look at you man I'm in
but that's just from the neck up if you
were to undress Mikhail you would find
yourself looking at like a body
something sure yeah 80 or elective gross
disgusting guys I see at the sauna like
oh dude you're really old with like a be
stronger than me yeah like a white chest
hair main this is unkempt that's Mikhail
Linden yeah who just turned 75 yeah 103
well done man well I hope you enjoyed
the big four Oh from my understanding
you are not a virgin so I can't connect
that title to you either way thanks
buddy
much love subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell catch you
guys soon